well yeah from the ice to the streets
we're continuing our vgk coverage of how
you can take your home team Pride all
around the valley here via your license
plate I'm live over here at the DMV near
Sahara and Eastern Avenues to talk about
the growing Trend there for that vgk
specialty license plate now as far as
those numbers there latest DMV numbers
show that the knights plate is the
second most popular specialty plate at
nearly 66 000 active car registrations
that's up 700 from last month Up 3 000
from last year it's the second most
popular specialty plate behind the Las
Vegas commemorative plate and that's the
one with the welcome to Fabulous Las
Vegas sign on it that one has 80 000
driving around the Valley now the
numbers are these numbers are active
registrations not sales the vgk plate
debuted back in October 2018. now if you
do want to swap out your plate and you
don't have any renewals or smog checks
if you just have your existing Nevada
registration the DMV's website says
there's a 5 dollar substitution fee and
then 37 dollars for that standard Vegas
born plate if you want to personalize it
further it's 72 dollars and live out
here again near the DMV near Sahara and
Eastern Avenues Lorna Grady 8 news now
back to you guys